gary Danielson CBSsports lead college
football analyst he was on the call for
the Iron Bowl with Auburn and Alabama
Auburn's 48 points in Saturday's win the
most against a Nick Saban coach team you
have to go back to Michigan State when
Saban was there 1999 they gave up 52 to
a Purdue team that was led by Drew Brees
gary Danielson joining us Gary good
morning what surprised you most about
that game with Alabama and Auburn huh
that it you know matched up and in some
ways overshadowed the kick six game I
mean that'll never be an ending like
that but for all the moving parts in
that game and you know the Gus has got a
strange offense and Nick is substituting
on every play on defense there's just a
lot of moving parts and that six minutes
at the end of the half I've never seen
anything like that you know I've been
doing it for over 25 done 500 live games
I've never seen anything like that but
you also have this team I think you have
a Nick Saban coach team that has all
these penalties I guess it's just
surprising that you you know they may
pride themselves in their defense and
you don't commit penalties and they
weren't good in either category against
all that I think then there's no doubt
that the Alabama team was feeling the
pressure in this football game let's say
they were feeling the past history of
Alabama being in the playoffs they knew
they had to come in and beat a really
good Auburn team I have to say if all
Byrne would have gotten one of those
transfer Rijo quarterbacks this might be
the top team in the country they played
an unbelievable schedule for them to
only lose three games they have a you
know a championship defense and in
modern-day football championship defense
is not holding teams to ten 11 points
back in the day you know when I went up
against those Bears defenses I mean if
you got three first downs in a row you
were happy at the game that the game has
changed but I think the Alabama team
really felt that you know they had to
come through they had a new quarterback
and you could see it they were
overreacting
emotionally to plays that they used to
be able to handle pretty easily we like
to play the hypothetical if Bama had TOA
how different is the outcome I actually
think they would have bought both games
as good as LSU was two was so rusty in
that football game you know the downside
of the tightrope ankle surgery that 2a
had was maybe instead of being for that
game 70% he might have been 85% but what
happened is he had to take two full
weeks off of practice where if you have
a sprained ankle I played with a high
ankle sprain you practice you just
limped in practice and I think him
taking those days off really was first
half of that game two was not the same
you know Dan you see these receivers
they they have for NFL receivers they
have the modern-day football they really
have for Antonio Browns on the field
without the baggage that's how good they
are and there's no college team that can
slow these guys down with two on his
game so I saw one projection that
Alabama would have ten of the top 50
players drafted I mean they Clem's in an
ohio state have really separated
themselves for talent that's going on
right now in college football I know
this probably isn't your wheelhouse but
you played the position if you were
gonna look at Joe Burrell at LSU and
twoa and kind of yeah fast forward to
what kind of pro quarterback you know we
had Rick Neuheisel on a couple of weeks
ago and he said Joe burrow is reminds
him of a young Tom Brady I mean you
can't get any higher praise the men know
that that's true and I I did hear Rick
talk about that you know Rick Rick is a
really good eye a sharp eye for talent I
do think he has some of the traits some
of the leadership traits that Brady has
and maybe he had that chip on his
shoulder you know by being an Ohio kid
and not winning that job when he thought
he was good enough to win it so I think
that comparison could hang there in his
stature and the way he plays style wise
and it goes back aways it may hit you
more than you know maybe some of your
listen
but he actually reminds me of Kenny
Anderson the way he plays football Jenny
was the best for those years and I think
he'd be a great fit for Cincinnati
I really do too is different in a lot of
ways he has a spatial awareness that you
know only a few people have you know the
Aaron Rodgers the Drew Brees the Magic
Johnson's the Isiah Thomas is that see
space or other people people see picket
fences they see the holes between the
picket fences yeah I never had that
ability you know it was more of a grind
for me to me - is Kurt Warner the way he
can deliver the deep ball and see plays
unfold he just has a a gift I don't
think it's an unteachable gift now you
know everybody has an Achilles heel
nobody gets it all and - maybe a little
more injury prone I I don't know you
know I
everybody gets a sprained ankle I
remember Matthew Stafford earliest
career with the Lions he got injured a
few times and everybody said he was
going to be injury prone and then he he
got over it he had a great run of place
you know so I think two is worth the
risk
I really do because I just think he's a
special player he's gary Danielson
former NFL quarterback CBSsports lead
college football analyst if you were the
Michigan athletic director what would
you do I love Jim Harbaugh I have to say
I thought Jim Harbaugh was going to do
to Michigan what Kirby Smart has done to
Georgia it's the same hire if you ask me
you know bringing back Kirby a next
player bringing back Jim I'm shocked
what's happened in the last three years
watching Ohio State's players their
impact players all over the field and
seeing the difference between them and
watching Michigan's players it just
looked like their space that wasn't
there what three years ago when it was a
fourth down play it just looked like
they've they've separated I have to say
um for a long time
I don't know the resume that Urban Meyer
has put on his coaching tree you know
what he did all the way from Bowling
Green he basically got Utah into the
pac-12 he rebuilt a kind of a fun and
gun soft Florida team in the national
championships by toughing them up and
then he goes up to Ohio State and has
taken they yeah you know this a house
that has always had great players every
NFL game I watch there's three guys from
Ohio State playing on the team I mean
it's amazing but he's taking them to the
next level and give give credit to coach
day but that program was built by her
I'm telling you right now I love playing
with the Lions and love playing with the
Cleveland Browns if I'm the Cleveland
Browns I go tell Urban Meyer what do you
want you want you know what do you want
10% of the ownership I will give you a
Pat Riley deal come over here do this
make us back into the Cleveland Browns
and you can represent us forever because
he's from that area and I just can't
believe how what an impact Urban Meyer
has had in college football like you
know these guys are control freaks
though Gary I can't see a college coach
and we've seen college coaches try it
and a lot of times it doesn't work
because they're so used to having these
kids for at least three years they can
redshirt you there and can they have
total autonomy you know it's like urban
talking about me Oh could he coach the
Dallas Cowboys I don't see it because
he'd have Jerry Jones there with him no
I think the Dallas Cowboys would be a
tough fit you know he might get him one
championship but then like Jimmie
Johnson it might not work long long term
and I think if you had an owner that
stepped aside and let him have autonomy
I don't know why you know he could be a
to me he could be a Bill Belichick now
the thing that bill has you know my
first team on the Lions bill was our
tight end coach so I go all the way back
with I know he was a he was a basically
an assistant coach you know one of those
grad assistant coaches Rick for Zano
who had maybe ties hired Bill for that
spot you know what he came came in and
we remember him as going to be a great
coach someday
is build does have those NFL ties you
know he he adores the old part of the
NFL the 70s in the 80s he loves those
guys you know so he has that connection
so your points pretty good III get that
but man if you're Cleveland or those
fans deserve a little better I was there
for the fumble I was there for the drive
you know there's no better fans of the
league and I just wish they could have
their team you know yeah be what they
should be so you were nitta-san
bystander when Elway had the drive you
know I always listened your show and I
always think like I wish I was as funny
as Reggie Miller and those guys I'm just
not who know me think I'm funny people
don't don't
yes yes I was there for the drive I
remember those Brian Brennan a little
receiver you know every day in practice
he would beat Frank Minnifield in
hanford diction our two corners every
day beat him like a drum and he'd be so
mad that he didn't get Wes Welker
numbers nowadays you know and he catches
the pass with two minutes to go and
Elwes not having a great game on that
drive you know so the last thing I ever
believed in momentum because we kickoff
we got the lead
they always not playing well he gets the
ball on the two yard line he's going
into the wind into the best defense in
the league into the dog pound and he
takes it 98 yards you can take momentum
and shove it right up the dog I'll leave
you with this Gary how does this play
out that fourth team in if it is Ohio
State it's LSU and it's Clemson who is
number four I know they're gonna be
happy to get the fourth spot we're gonna
have a tough matchup I'll tell you that
because it looks like Ohio State and
Clemson you know and LSU LSU all three
of them are gonna be a tough matchup you
know I sure do beat LSU
they're going to get the fourth spot but
you know I think the other three teams
eating's them lose their last game are
in so their fourth spot to me if LSU
beats Georgia I think it's the term for
the pac-12 to get a shot if you ties up
beaten organ
I think the pac-12 has had a better
conference this year and Utah's had a
better season than Oklahoma but I we've
seen Oklahoma I'd give the shot that
Utah
yeah but it's a TV show Gary and I I
wonder if that name recognition with
Oklahoma Trump's Utah I I know a lot of
people say that but I actually have a
lot of faith I don't I don't like I
would not like to be one of those 13
people choosing but I do think they have
a lot of respect for college football a
choose brand names just for ratings I
just don't believe that's the case so I
give them the credit they're all
excellently know people they try to do
their best I don't think they would play
a TV show type situation great to talk
to Gary as always we appreciate your
time thank you thank you that's gary
Danielson for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]